have you heard the news we're in a clean
energy revolution where I live in
Berkeley California it seems like every
day I see a new roof with new solar
panels going up electric car on the
driveway Germany sometimes gets half its
power from solar and India is now
committed to building 10 times more
solar than we have in California by the
year 2022 even nuclear seems to be
making a comeback Bill Gates is in China
working with engineers there's 40
different companies that are working
together to try to race to build the
first reactor that runs on waste that
can't melt down and it's cheaper than
coal and so you might start to ask is
this whole global warming problem going
to be a lot easier to solve than anybody
imagined that was the question we wanted
to know and so my colleagues and I
decided to take a deep dive into the
data we were a little skeptical of some
parts of the clean energy revolution
story but what we found really surprised
us so the first thing is that clean
energy has been increasing this is
electricity from clean energy sources
over the last 20 years but when you look
at the percentage of global electricity
from clean energy sources it's actually
been in decline from 36% to 31% and if
you care about climate change you've got
to go in the opposite direction to a
hundred percent of our electricity from
clean energy sources as quickly as
possible now you might wonder how much
could five percentage points of global
electricity be well it turns out to be
quite a bit it's the equivalent of 60
nuclear plants the size of Diablo Canyon
California's last nuclear plant or 900
solar farms the size of topaz which is
one of the biggest solar farms in the
world and certainly our biggest in
California well a big part of this is
just simply that fossil fuels are
increasing faster than clean energy and
that's understandable there's just a lot
of poor countries that are still using
wood and dung and charcoal
as their main source of energy and they
need modern fuels but there's something
else going on which is that one of those
clean energy sources in particular has
actually been on the decline in absolute
terms not just relatively and that's
nuclear you can see its generation has
declined 7% over the last 10 years now
solar and wind have been making huge
strides and so you hear a lot of talk
about how it doesn't really matter
because solar and wind is going to make
up the difference but the data says
something different when you combine all
the electricity from solar and wind you
see it actually barely makes up half of
the decline from nuclear well let's take
a closer look in the United States over
the last couple of years really 2013
2014 we prematurely retired for nuclear
power plants they were almost entirely
replaced with fossil fuels and so the
consequence was that we wiped out almost
as much clean energy electricity that we
get from solar and it's not unique to us
and people think of California as a
clean energy and climate leader but when
we looked at the data what we found is
that in fact California reduced
emissions more slowly than the national
average between 2000 and 2015
what about Germany they're doing a lot
of clean energy but when you look at the
data German emissions have actually been
going up since 2009 and there's really
not anybody who's going to tell you that
they're going to meet their climate
commitments in 2020 the reason isn't
hard to understand solar and wind
provide power about 10 to 20 percent of
the time which means that when the sun's
not shining the winds not blowing you
still need power for your hospitals your
homes your cities your factories and
while batteries have made some really
cool improvements lately the truth is
that they're just never going to be as
efficient as the electrical grid every
time you put electricity into a battery
and you take it out you lose about
twenty to forty percent of the power
that's why when in California we try to
deal with all the solar we've brought
online we now get about 10% of our
electricity from solar when the Sun Goes
Down and people come home from work and
their air conditioners and their TV sets
and every other appliance in the house
we need a lot of natural gas backup so
what we've been doing is stuffing a lot
of natural gas into the side of the
mountain and that worked pretty well for
a while but then late last year it
sprung a leak
this is Aliso Canyon and so much methane
gas was released it was the equivalent
of putting a half a million cars on the
road it basically blew through all of
our climate commitments for the year
well what about India sometimes you have
to go places to really get the right
data so we travel to India a few months
ago we met with all the top officials
solar nuclear at the rest and what they
told us is they said we're actually
having more serious problems than both
Germany and California we don't have
backup we don't have all the natural gas
and that's just the start of it we say
we want to get to 100 gigawatts by 2022
but last year we did just five and the
year before that we did five so let's
just take a closer look at nuclear the
United Nations Intergovernmental Panel
on Climate Change has looked at the
carbon content of all these different
fuels and nuclear comes out really low
it's actually lower even than solar and
nuclear obviously provides a lot of
power 24 hours a day seven days a week
during a year a single plant can provide
power 92 percent of the time and what's
interesting is that when you look at
countries that have deployed different
kinds of clean energies there's only a
few that have done so at a pace
consistent with dealing with the climate
crisis so nuclear seems like a pretty
good option but there's this big problem
with it which all of you I'm sure are
aware of which is that people really
don't like it there was a study a survey
done of people around the world not just
in the United States or Europe about a
year and a half ago and what they found
is that nuclear is actually one of the
least popular forms of energy even oil
is more popular than nuclear and while
nuclear kind of edges out coal the thing
is people don't really fear coal in the
same way that they fear nuclear which
really operates on our unconscious so
what is it that we fear I mean is really
three things there's the safety of the
plants themselves the fears that they're
going to meltdown a cause damage
there's the waste from them
and then there's the association with
weapons and I think understandably
engineers look at those concerns and
they want to look for technological
fixes I mean that's why Bill Gates is in
China developing advanced reactors
that's why 40 different entrepreneurs
are working on this problem and and I
myself have been very excited about it
we did a report how to make nuclear
cheap in particular the thorium reactor
shows a lot of promise and so when the
climate scientist James Hansen asked if
I wanted to go to China with him and
look at the Chinese advanced nuclear
program I jumped at the chance we were
there with MIT and UC Berkeley engineers
and you know I had in my mind that the
Chinese would be able to do with nuclear
what they did with so many other things
just start to crank out small nuclear
reactors on assembly lines and ship them
up like iPhones or MacBooks and send
them around the world I would get one in
home in Berkeley but what I found was
somewhat different the presentations
were all very exciting and very
promising they have multiple reactors
that they're working on the time came
for the thorium reactor and a bunch of
us were excited they went through the
whole presentation that got to the
timeline and they said we're going to
have a thorium molten-salt reactor ready
for sale to the world by 2040 and I was
like what looks at my colleagues I was
like excuse me can you guys speed that
up a little bit because we're in a
little bit of a climate crisis right now
and your cities are really polluted by
the way and they kind of responded back
they were like I'm not sure but you've
heard about our thorium program but we
don't have a third of our budget and
your Department of Energy hasn't been
particularly forthcoming with all that
data you guys have on testing reactors
and I said well I've got an idea you
know how you got 10 years where you're
demonstrating that reactor let's just
skip that part and let's just go right
to commercializing it that'll save money
and time and the engineer just looked at
me and he said let me ask you a question
would you buy a car that had never been
demonstrated before so what about the
other reactors there's a reactor that's
coming online now they're starting to
sell it it's a high temperature gas
reactor it can't melt down but it's
really big and bulky
part of the safety and nobody thinks
it's going to ever get cheaper than the
reactors that we have the ones that use
waste is fuel are really cool ideas but
the truth is we don't actually know how
to do that yet there's some risk that
you actually will make more waste and
most people think that if you're
including that waste part of the process
it's just going to make the whole
machine a lot more expensive it's just
adding another complicated step and the
truth is that there's real questions
about how much of that we're going to do
I mean we went to India and asked about
the nuclear program the government said
before Paris climate talks that they
were going to do something like 30 new
nuclear plants but when we got there and
we interviewed people and we even looked
at the internal documents they're now
saying they're going to do about five
and in most of the world especially the
rich world they're not talking about
building new reactors we're actually
talking about taking reactors down
before their lifetimes are over Germany
is actually pressuring its neighbors to
do that I mentioned the United States we
could lose half of our reactors over the
next 15 years which would wipe out 40%
of the emissions reductions were
supposed to get under the clean power
plan and of course in Japan they took
all the nuclear plants offline replace
them with coal natural gas oil burning
and they're only expected to bring
online about 1/3 to 2/3 so when we kind
of went through the numbers and just
added that up how much nuclear do we see
China and India bringing online over the
next 15 years how much do we see at risk
of being taken offline this was the most
startling finding what we found is that
the world is actually at risk of losing
four times more clean energy than we
lost over the last ten years in other
words we're not in a clean energy
revolution we're in a clean energy
crisis so it's understandable that
engineers would look for technical fix
to the fears that people have of nuclear
but when you consider that these are big
challenges to do that they're going to
take a long time to solve there's this
other issue which is that are those
technical fixes really going to solve
people's fears let's take safety you
know despite what people think it's hard
to figure out how to make nuclear power
much safer I mean
every medical journal that looks at it
this is the most recent study from the
British journal Lancet one of the most
respected journals in the world nuclear
is the safest way to make reliable power
everybody's are scared of the accident
so you go look at the accident data
Fukushima Chernobyl World Health
Organisation finds the same thing the
vast majority of harm is caused by
people panicking and they're panicking
because they're afraid in other words
the harm that's caused isn't actually
caused by the machines or the radiation
it's caused by our fears and what about
look at the waste everyone worries about
the waste well the interesting about the
waste is how little of it there is this
is just from one plant if you take all
the nuclear waste we've ever made in the
United States put it on a football field
stacked it up it would only reach 20
feet high and people say it is poisoning
people are doing something that's not
it's just sitting there it's just being
monitored there's not very much of it by
contrast the waste that we don't control
from energy production we call it
pollution and it kills seven million
people a year and it's threatening very
serious levels of global warming and the
truth is that even if we get good at
using that waste as fuel there's always
going to be some fuel left over and that
means there's always going to be those
people that think it's a big problem for
reasons that maybe don't have as much to
do with the actual waste as we think
well what about the weapons maybe the
most surprising thing is that we can't
find any examples of countries that have
nuclear power and then Oh decide to go
get a weapon in fact it works the
opposite what we find is that the only
way we know how to get rid of large
numbers of nuclear weapons is by using
the plutonium and the warheads as fuel
in our nuclear power plants and so if
you are wanting to get the world rid of
nuclear weapons then we're going to need
a lot more nuclear power
as I was leaving China the engineer that
brought bill gates there kind of pulled
me aside and he said you know Michael I
appreciate your interest and all the
different nuclear supply technologies
but there's this more basic issue which
is that there's just not enough global
demand I mean we can crank out these
machines on assembly lines we do know
how to make things cheap but there's
just not enough people that want them
and so let's do solar and wind and
efficiency and conservation let's
accelerate the advanced nuclear programs
I think we should triple the amount of
money we're spending on it but I just
think the most important thing if we're
going to overcome the climate crisis is
to keep in mind that the cause of the
clean energy crisis isn't from within
our machines
it's from within ourselves thank you
very much
you